τμεθυσμό για τς εξαρτίσεις όχει μόνο του ζόγου και για άλλά θέματα γιατί για μας
έχει σημασί α ν τα παιδιά να έχουνταις δεξιότητες να πουν όχι να έχουν την
κριτική σκέψει να κατανοήσουν πιο είναι το καλόν και ποιο είνα το κακό για των
εαυτόν τους και τους γύρω τους συνέπως εκεί είναι που στο χεύουμε σας αρχισαμε το
κινητό αλλά θέρο να ρωτήσω ποια είναι ιάθυνα μιχαλιαναι μεκαθορίζηνομίζω το χαρακτηριστικών το επίθετω τις
δασκάλας είναι εκπαιδευτικώς και είμαι πολύ περήφανι που είναι εκπαιδευτικός έχει καθορήσει όλι την πορεία
μου και ως μητέρα και ως προσωπικόητα και ως φίλι κυρίως όμως ως επαγγελματείας νομίζωμε
χαρακτηρίζει αυτό αυτή η διότητα μου πέραντούτου είμαι η καιρηνιώτησα ηοι γυναίκα που έχει ζήσει
τον πόλεμο πρόλαβα αναδιώσολα αυτά για τα οποία μιλάμε και θέλουμε να μεταδώσουμε στα παιδιά
τούτον μιλόγιδι και συγκινούμε γιατί φέρνω στιμνίουμ ικόνες μυροδιές όπως λέω πολλές φορές ίχους αυτά
δε θα μονταστερήσει ποτέ κανένας είναι στο μυαλόμου και δεν ξεχνοκαιόλα σε αυτό που ε
έχει περάσει ου πατέρασμου οποίος δυστυχώς πέθαν επρινα ρκετα χρόνια με την αγάπη του για
των τόπον του ήταν και στρατιωτικός αντιλαμβάτνεστε τότι παιδί μου ότι έχουμε στο νούμας είτε
είναι μόρφωση τηείνα εμπειρίες που κουβαλάμεν τε είναι ικόνεςετε είναι αναμνήσεις δεν μπορεί κανείς να
μας τα αστερήσει γιατί προφανώς τους είχαν στερήσει αλλά πράγματα με τον πόλεμα το ιστεκπαιδευτικώς
και βρεθειναμε το τημόνι το υπουργείου παιδίας είναι γι αυτόν τον λόγο που ποτέ ενά
μη συχρόνο τώρα δεν ακούστηκε ποτέ κάτι κάπό γιατί αθυνά μιχαηλίδ ότι έκανε κάποιον λάθος
όποτε έπεσε το θέμα των αθηματισμού ου δεποτε επεσε θέμα για την υπουργόν παιδίας είναι
ένα παράδειγμα ότι αυτός που θα μπει σε ένα υπουργείο